groupie you are our new jeopardy
champion worth ten thousand dollars
congratulations
steve congratulations what a game you
just defeated
a six-time jeopardy champ how do you
feel it's amazing i mean i got to meet
zach backstage
before some of his previous victories
what a great guy
he was so full of confidence and
everything i thought i had no chance at
all
so it feels amazing i'm still sort of in
a fog after it happened
now how important is this first win the
first win takes the pressure off because
you know if you lose on jeopardy
straight out of the gate or you do
below your capabilities you're going to
feel bad
but so far everybody i've seen even the
people who don't win they're performing
at a very high level
so for me to pull off that first victory
i was stunned and you can't imagine how
it feels
when it comes to emotions what comes to
mind when you think about this entire
experience the entire experience well
you know i was worried that
you know all my reading or podcast
listening and all the stuff that i've
done to just
enjoy knowledge i was worried whether it
would pay off or not
and it absolutely paid off because there
were numerous questions
that tied in directly to stuff that i
had listened to either for enjoyment or
for educational purposes
and so all that hard work paid off
what's it like meeting ken
ken is such a professional uh i mean i
can remember back in
when i was in college watching
contestants like chuck forrest
and i thought oh my gosh that guy is
amazing a true genius who can ever
out do somebody like that and then ken
comes along and just
obliterates all the records and then to
have him
here carrying on alex's legacy it's
absolutely perfect
who in your life do you think will be
most proud of you at this moment
i think my dad especially when i got
some science questions right
he's 96 years old and he was a great
engineer for many years building
components that went into space missions
and when i got a question right in the
science category i thought
okay i didn't proud you're so much fun
to watch good luck in your next game
thank you jimmy